The main thing to remember about operant conditioning is that reinforcement
always increases the future likelihood of a behavior occurring, and punishment
always decreases the likelihood of behavior occurring. Let's take a look at
this two by two table of operant consequences. Notice we have a plus and a
minus. You should think of this as adding something to the environment or
taking something away. Do not think of the plus and minus as good or bad. But
rather just a mathematical operation. So we have our operation. Are we adding
something or subtracting something? On the consequence side, we're going to
either add a reinforcer or remove a reinforcer. Let's think of our example with
Callie, when Dr Zelegg gave a piece of fish to Callie, she was using that fish
as a reinforcer, and it was an impetative stimulus something that we enjoy. We
can also increase behavior by removing something aversive. For example, you
wake up and your alarm clock is blaring loud, that's very aversive. You turn
your alarm clock off, you remove that aversivness from your environment and
you're likely to engage in that behavior again in the future. Reinforcer is
always increasing behavior. Let's look at punishers. In this box we would call
this positive reinforcement, because we're adding something to the enviornment.
In this box we call it negative reinforcement because we're taking something
away. We can also use these operations for punishment. For punisher, if we add
something aversive after a behavior occurs, we're going to see a decrease in
the likelihood of that behavior occurring in the future. We can also remove
something positive or appetitive and also see a decrease. So, for example, if
you touch a light switch with a wet hand and you get shocked, you're adding
pain to your environment and you probably won't do that again in the future.
Here, you're playing with your video games and you hit your brother and your
mum takes away your video games. You're losing something that you enjoy and
you're less likely to engage in that behavior again in the future. So in this
example, this would be positive punishment because you're adding a punisher.
And in this box, it would be negative punishment because you're taking away
something that is appetitive or something that we like and we also see a
decrease in behavior. Reinforcement increase, punishment decrease.